Democrats are increasingly turning some
are saying on Democratic senator from
California Dianne Feinstein and
demanding that she resign let me remind
everybody what is going on and there's a
lot of sad stuff going on in this story
Dianne Feinstein is currently the
longest serving member of the U.S Senate
she is 89 years old she is she has
announced she is not seeking re-election
in 2024.
there have been many concerns I want to
be as respectful as possible but also be
accurate there have been many concerns
for years now about Dianne Feinstein's
cognitive State there are public
examples tough to watch I admit public
examples of Dianne Feinstein asking a
witness during a senate hearing a
question
hearing an answer from the witness and
then looking down at her papers and
asking the exact same question a second
time seemingly forgetting that she just
asked that question there are endless
reports from staffers and people in DC
who work at the Senate saying Dianne
Feinstein regularly will meet someone
that she has met many times before even
recently and has no recollection of
having met that person so listen I mean
we don't have a diagnosis here but there
have been concerns for years about this
as far as Dianne Feinstein goes it is
the right decision at this point she had
a great run to not run for re-election
in 2024. what has surfaced uh in the
wake of this is that there is a primary
in California in which three members of
the House of Representatives uh have
decided to run for Dianne Feinstein's
senate seat that's Adam Schiff who we've
interviewed uh Barbara Lee who we're
going to interview and Katie Porter who
we would like to interview but so far
has not responded to our requests you
can't run for House and Senate at the
same time meaning that while all three
of them Barbara Lee Adam Schiff and
Katie Porter who are mid 70s early 60s
and around 50 years old respectively
while they are all competing for the
senate seat
their congressional seats are now going
to be open because they can't run for
both at the same time Dianne Feinstein
on top of this as is reported by
Newsweek has recently been out with
shingles and this is particularly
impactful because Dianne Feinstein is on
the Judiciary Committee and when you
have such a divided government the way
we have right now where Democrats barely
control the Senate judicial appointees
are one of the relatively few ways that
Democrats can assert power use their
majority and try to assist Joe Biden in
getting things done because of Dianne
Feinstein's absence from that committee
it has effectively made it impossible
for Senate Democrats to continue
confirming Joe Biden's judicial
nominations so both because it would
potentially allow a different dynamic in
the primary which would be better for
Democrats and because of this issue on
the Senate uh Judiciary more and more
Democrats are saying that Diane
Feinstein should resign right now if
Diane Einstein did resign and Farren
cousins talked about this one filling in
for me last week to some degree the
governor of California currently
Democratic governor Gavin Newsom would
get to replace a point a replacement to
fill the vacancy now you have to
understand that there are different
Dynamics in California depending on how
long it is until the next general
election if Dianne Feinstein were to
resign within six months of the general
election there wouldn't be a special
election for the seat you would just
wait until
um uh the the general election when you
have under I'm sorry when you have more
than 180 days left then you would do a
special election right now because we
have more than 180 days until the 2024
uh election if Dianne Feinstein resigned
today
um you would see the appointment by
Gavin Newsom and then you would see a
special election that is potentially a
much better path forward both number one
because of its impact on the Senate
Judiciary Committee and number two
because it might actually change the
game with regard to so many Democratic
open seats in the House of
Representatives that increasingly
Democrats are saying that is exactly
what should be done uh it doesn't appear
as though right now there is Big
momentum for Dianne Feinstein to
actually do that and it's unclear
whether that is going to change the
other aspect to this that's being
discussed is what about appointing a
replacement on the Judiciary Committee
for Dianne Feinstein I don't have a lot
of news to give you about that right now
but it is certainly something that is
being discussed my leaning right now
is that it would probably be a good idea
for Dianne Feinstein to resign
what exactly the timing of that would be
and this issue of the replacement versus
getting back to the Senate Judiciary
Committee I don't know it's not about
again it's not about stigmatizing it's
not about making fun of any it's not
about any of these things it's about a
political expediency and Feinstein has
had an incredible run in the Senate has
accomplished so much iconic in so many
different ways nothing is being taken
away from her in my mind if she did
resign uh Republicans are jumping all
over this and saying she should not
resign and now Democrats are being bad
in some way by urging her to do so this
is of course Republicans concerned only
with self-preservation and realizing
that it's actually been a great thing
for them that Joe Biden's judicial
nominees have been held up as a result
of this so I I quite frankly could not
care less what Republicans uh say they
just want whatever is best for them it
does seem overall that what's best for
the Senate and what's best for Democrats
would would be for Dianne Feinstein to
resign I'm willing to change my mind if
you disagree with me simply let me know
in a comment in an email in a tweet